in my early days of standing on stage
I'd be at these amazing conferences with
these other incredible speakers and I
was like what am I doing here and I
remembered that somebody else has
already vetted me I didn't have to prove
that I was worthy of being there and I
didn't have to posture because someone
else has already decided that I can be
on the stage do those people sometimes
make mistakes damn straight they do but
at the end of the day it's accepting
that you're not the only person that got
you there other people opened doors for
you and other people said yes do you
belong and it's trust that they know
what they're doing that has helped me a
great deal the other big thing that I do
is I remind myself that I have something
of value I know it has value and I'm
here to give it away so I I change my
mentality to I I hope they like me I
hope they think this is good or why am I
here to well I'm just going to give what
I've got and if they like it they like
it and if they don't they don't but I'm
just here to give and so that service
mentality has really helped me over the
years